che succede
sai di varese oggi giocheremo nuovissimo
gioco in cui bisogna scappare dal ratto
gira e verdi avete capito bene il suo
bologna no perché ma è uno dei giochi
più popolari al momento su rob lowe a 60
mila mi piace
stanno giocando tutti quindi noi
vogliamo scoprire a piacere e così
popolare al momento questo gioco
vogliamo punto provarlo anche noi ma voi
lasciato un bel giovanotto e
consigliateci pure che altri giochi
provare su rob lowe cso fuori da robot
pronti mettetevi comodi prendete i pop
corn e inizia famoso vita qui c'è già un
pezzo di formaggio vi sarebbero reale
aprire il formaggio per aprire la porta
ok
[Musica]
c'è quindi siamo dentro un formaggio e
di formaggio gigante allora questa porta
si apre questa porta pazze del formaggio
è andato a male nel senso verde dove
l'aspetta no no no è un labirinto
gigante successo che mi perderò ad
intonare vitale si perde sempre nailah
binti trovato qualcosa per entrare qua
un fast life con il formaggio puzzone
bale
senza di rumori strani ecco se ne va
tutto il mio torneo
scappa scappa
via devi proprio là dentro
è stato pulito e super casino
che hai
miley non può passare
sono salvata non ci posso credere
quest'anno salvatore
modo di provare nuovi pezzi di un
omaggio collezionare nuovi pezzi di
formaggio allora sensi farsi aspetto che
fa si è aspetto che arrivi vitale a
proposito a proposito di cose paurose
grazie mille per tutti i messaggi che mi
state mandando sul mio libro storie
paurose a scuola di misteri vi sta
piacendo tante scelte prese in
tantissimi super contento di leggere i
vostri messaggi e sapere quale parte vi
piaciuta di più quale creatura vi
piaciuta di più perché è pieno di
illustrazioni con le schede creatura
fatemi sapere nei commenti a che pagina
siete qual è la vostra creatura
preferita con la vostra storia preferita
tra l'altro lo sapevate che questo
cerchietto qua con me merlino in realtà
è un adesivo infatti se volete potete
attaccarlo e attaccarlo dove volete tipo
quelli delle mele
io procedo
ma che ben si fa questo top o non
piaccia trovato è ok sono morta anch'io
no possiamo vincere insieme ho trovato
un pezzo di formaggio vabbè circe circhi
aiutami a scappare ma per tutto il
calcio questo dopo mai arrivato
no è troppo veloce
ci sono le sei zone
di salvataggio c'è fatto lui non può
entrare quant'altro io sono lì adesso
che i ragazzi concentriamoci dobbiamo
trovare quanti erano 79 99 pezzi di
formaggio
di questi stanno fermi qua è perché
stanno aspettando chi che lo sgambetto
sì credo che lui sia più vicino guarda
cos'è un lucchetto rosso sicuramente
dobbiamo trovare una chiesa carne rossa
abbiamo di qualche cosa c'è
nella sexton ma questo l'inizio sì o no
giusto labirinto
riproviamoci vogliamo a prendere
un'altra strada anche se non mi ricordo
quale è nata come prete prima o no e
basta a battere
ho preso un altro pezzo di formaggio a
12 di nove
che voglio vedere
che ora io evitare uniremo le forze e
proveremo a cerchiamo di capire dove sta
rendere tutti i pezzi di formaggio e
trovare la chiave rossa allora qui mi sa
che siamo già passati però bastava ed
era
rimasta rincorrendo
rimando tutto qui c'è un tubo o quando
sono andata poi
è vero c'è qualcun altro non ce la porta
ok
maggio browser 33 dino perso una volta
che prendiamo tutti i pezzi di formaggio
riusciremo a trovare la chiave può
essere
che cos'è queste 39 a questo non
aspetta e vedi se lui è qui ho visto
qualcosa perché a ostia
so che parte non lo so lo sappiamo dalla
casa scavolini villini quello piccolo
ok qua siamo già passati ad andare da
qualche altra parte
e questo piccolo qui
ma anche corsa leggera preso
scappati no
è
riuscita a scappare fatto non lo so
giusto in tempo
sembra che ci sia un terremoto ogni
volta che possano
fatto che sono pepe chiavi preferì
formarsi
lui perché il topo ride così male ma
ehi ma questi non si muovono d'acqua
come è possibile che fanno sempre fermi
quando ma me la sono cercata questa
volta più
approfittato preso fosse riuscito a
prendere il prezzo di formali
ma ho già preso tutto potete andare
allora io penso che aver capito dove
all'entrata
ho trovato un altro pezzo di formaggio
ho trovato la chiave verde non si tu
dove sei motori anch'io come sono
arrivato qua ho seguito un corridoio
lunghissimo ma cosa tremando tutto che
sta succedendo
non si credo che finalmente ho trovato
un passaggio vediamo cosa si e quattro
no nelle tubature portano altro pezzo di
formaggio scrivo e ora devo trovare la
chiave blu si capisce è la chiave verde
adesso che però è dietro quindi ora
prova ad aprire la porta o verde e
magari trovare una chiave blu anche se
non mi ricorderò come arrivare qua
assai presto
questo forse scende
si scese giù ok troviamo la piccola
portare le logge prima facie reti in 33
entra
che succede
indovina il codice di 4 cifre 2483
oppure 2843 me c'è scritto 2483 proviamo
a vincere 2 48 33 spero sia giusto
vediamo no è sbagliato e proprio con 284
38 42 palco del codice proviamo a
mettere al contrario
bravo era quello il contrario ma perché
mi vedo così perché non c'è più il mio
personaggio
cosa mi muovo così un pezzo di formaggio
una maggiore ma tutto
vita è un posto molto strano questo
addio paura che stia arrivando il topo
gigante arrivarmi tutti i pezzi di
formaggio che sono riuscite a rubargli
forse questa è la casa del topino cosa
c'è solo è tutto molto strano
però se la chiamerò se almeno a un pezzo
di formaggio è anche un
non specula successo non mi ha fatto
prendere la chiave rossa
vorrei formaggio era una trappola dei
vari problemi si crede di dover
rientrare in quella cosa perde sì perché
diceva che
era bravo romiti e ora come faccio a
tornare dove la porta a perdere mi
ricordo io dov'ero rapporto verdeblu chi
è questo
rapporto dovrebbe essere qui dietro la
borsa
no vabbè non ho neanche più la chiave o
ok ragazzi riproviamo l'ultima volta
lasciate su mi piace di incoraggiamento
qua sotto per portarci fortuna perché
state seguendo tutti i me perché tu non
conosci la strada è insomma vi sembra
che allora era un corridoio lunghissimo
eccolo porto verde per
tutti aspetta tutti che sono rilanciare
la perdita d'acqua ma non si può
risalire
forse dobbiamo seguire lui per sapere la
soluzione proviamo a seguirlo togliamo
questo succede a quanti pezzi di
formaggio ipad
non è l'ultima idea direi accesi a
divenuta in seguito la cosa più
importante quanti pezzi di formaggio
allora ora provo a seguire uno di questi
giocatori vediamo se sono più bravi a
vista sono passato io
forse era questo forse a questo punto
sono
vicino in questo
gli un crollo trovato il 19 non mi devo
far prendere non devo cadere nelle sue
trappole questa volta possiamo partire
lo stare bene ma questo rientrando nella
porto questa volta non mi faccio fregare
da allora
ok allora bisogna voluto da bush in
questo posto stranissimo perché non si
sa che cos'è allora prendi prima la
chiave rossa mi raccomando non mi faccio
fregare questa volta non è ma aspetta un
momento è cambiato così prima a no
perché serviva il codice che era abbiamo
detto 384 aperto vedi anno c'è qualcosa
di strano c'è col quadro che la cosa
questo è il passaggio per sconfiggere il
ratto gigante notte invece no non porta
da nessuna parte eccoli però so che per
primi hanno subito la chiave è bravo
ok
quella latina invece che cosa non la sa
ma non voglio cadere nella sua trappola
qui mi usciamo da qua
un pezzo di formaggio ma
ce l'ho fatta ragazzi non avete idea di
quante volte ho provato quante volte vi
sono tracce della pa 7 di nuove rette di
no tutto ciò per prendere solo beretta e
performante ma
forse la ferita questa parte bianca
ok ora aspetta aspetta aspetta vice
[Musica]
non trovare la porta con lucchetto rosso
abbiamo avevamo senza morire
no no no ai browser mica fa dopo non
puoi prendermi ha detto che non lo
chiamerò per tutto questo per prendere
pensi di passaggio in rotta dai possa
cercare la porta rossa dove così ti
posso guidare ecco noi lo trovo trovata
brava non ci credo ragazzi adesso sono
entrata no
aspetta un momento che cosa non c'è
niente ottimo c'è niente qua dentro
besta del giro non ci credo aspetta
guarda bene guardati sopra
per niente è utile no cosa lo aspetta ho
preso una tavola
forse la tavola mi serve a qualcosa non
so che cosa
quando hai visto quando scendi da dato
pose che mette il codice manca un pezzo
di legno chi si mette il pezzo di legno
poi attraversare perché prendere la
chiave blu quindi quindi ritornare sopra
di nuovo tramite la chiave verde
proviamo telepass pensare che va da via
parlando tutto bene
provo a distrarlo
e via boccaccio
e qui spaventato moltissimo
quindi devo riandare alla porta blu alla
porta verde che dovrebbe essere poi
dietro se non sbaglio da qualche parte
qui
questo gioco è super
frustrante e quindi non lo continuerò a
meno che voi non insiste che volete
vedere il continuo a continuare a non
farsi tempo divertito idea è brutto che
dopo che ti prende non hai più né chiave
non hai più niente
ora vi lasciamo quattro casi lines
pubblicare provvedere inoltre altri
video e kakà su quella che preferite
monet